so glad to have these next guests with
me despite the technological nightmare
we've got two guests okay for a couple
of reasons let me set this up we've had
both of them on before milo yiannopoulos
of course a big contributor to breitbart
brilliant man and lovely and he's also a
super fan of another guest who is one of
our first guests on the program
dean kane so milo dean dean milo
cheers mate good to meet you
thanks so much timer stephen nice to
meet you
well yeah you're so civil now you were
like milo you were geeking out about it
over three like if you i don't know
anybody anything but if you could
introduce me to dean cain i owe you one
that wasn't quite what i said i think
what i said was oh yeah i don't know
that guy yeah i guess that would be cool
i mean if you really need a guest this
week i mean sure
i think i was way cooler about it than
that well
you said something interesting miles so
obviously dean i mean
you know lois and clark is what i grew
up on and then milo what do you call it
in the uk you don't say lois and clark
no i think we call it the new adventures
of superman which is a terrible name
way to insult him right off the bat i'm
aware of that though actually andy
peters who was a presenter out there in
the uk came on the show and i was over
there in the uk doing some promo and i
was aware every place you go it's
actually called something a little bit
differently uh they market it that way
that was back in the old days toilet
cleaner yes exactly
what do you call it there toilet cleaner
they call it toilet cleaner we call it
well i don't know i don't actually use
it i actually have
i don't know but maybe you need to wash
out your toilet mouth milo from the way
you were talking and complaining about
the technology before the break um okay
so milo you're a big fan of the new
adventures of superman dean do you find
that there's a different kind of fan in
the uk versus the united states like are
they i mean obviously milo's different
you know because he just has a total
crush on you but like for the general
fan oh my god shut up
well you know you find a different
reaction everywhere in some places this
is this was particularly true 20 years
ago it's not so much now because
everything gets released at the same
time
internationally you're showing something
here on netflix it's all over the place
and you can get it anywhere uh before it
was about three to six eight ten months
maybe sometimes a year before the show
would air in another country so um there
were certain areas of the show did very
well the uk australia france
um and there were places in brazil just
it's just odd where the show did well um
but i don't find that the fans to be
tremendously different i would imagine
that like in egypt they would have to
blur out like we talked about terry
hatcher's bosoms in the intro but in
france they would just photoshop it so
you could see nipple
and that's why i like france
and in the uk milo so i mean you guys
have a different rating was that
considered like a children's show there
or how was it seen yeah i mean i think
it was on around the time i got home
from school um
and
yeah
at the time which is great
yeah because i'm like so young did i
mention i'm really
young yeah so your tv show was on when i
was at school sorry about that but um no
i i i think it was
there were two things you could watch
when you got home from school you could
watch i think star trek voyager or the
star trek uh deep space nine or you
could watch a new adventure superman i
think they were on different channels um
so yeah no it was it was i mean i don't
think i know anybody who didn't watch it
they only had three channels by the way
there was bbc one bbc two in sky right
true
that's true i believe this is yeah
we don't have to close the channel now
you don't have lots of channels that you
do in the states although most of it is
entirely crap we were giving we were
given a cable box my wife and i come on
we invented most of your tv shows that's
true too good stuff
well all the game shows all the reality
shows all the stuff people like on
netflix is like remakes of 1990s and
1970s uh british tv shows orange is the
new black is a remake of bad girls from
itv in the 1990s um uh the the one with
kevin spacey house of cards is a remake
of something from bbc i mean we invented
all your good tv no i'm not gonna argue
with that oh no i don't you know the
problem is they'll have to come to the
united states to be successful milo's
still upset that they let their number
one draft pick get away i mean that's 16
times
but you still have canada as a
benchwarmer milo
yeah
well it's funny because you guys
actually copied a lot of stuff from
canada the newsroom in canada uh what
was it the larry sanders show newsroom
in canada was before the jeff jeff uh
jeff daniels there was one in canada it
was before curb your enthusiasm was
before the office it was called the
newsroom in canada and it was
uproariously funny and wildly
inappropriate but yeah there's a lot of
similarities between canadian television
i think in english television uh a lot
of quite an indictment on culture isn't
it that you canada as a as an
inspiration yes this is true um canada
is a silly place
but
and there aren't it's like kind of like
where you're from where i was from we
didn't have conservatives we had
liberals and we had liberal separatists
in quebec
um
which is not so okay so we have a call
we have an eclectic mix so dean cain
last time you were on uh he's his full
name dean kane that's all right
it's been happening my whole life you're
not dean
no i'm i'm i'm two little steam kane
just two pops before we get into that
have you seen the sketch uh where co the
guy who does this picture-perfect
impression of kojak and he references
you no i want to he comes back and he's
like he's coming back as kojak but
beating up hipsters he's like you
hipsters don't know what a real man's
like with your dean keynes you're david
barianzis you're pretty boys so he just
like uses you as a reference as this
pretty boy non-real man as a pretty boy
that's what he's that's all right that's
i mean you're prettier than kojak it's a
pretty word i don't think that's true i
don't think that's true both of these
examples are wrong i'm about as far
removed as a hit from a hipster as it's
possible to get and my two crushes were
dean kane and david brianna um so yeah i
think it's complete it's completely
wrong i mean on the one hand you've got
you know the very sort of broadly
ambiguous and complex character superman
and on the other you've got this like
brooding undead dude these aren't
hipster icons these are you know this is
this is um no no this is he's entirely
wrong about that i'm sure it's very
funny but it's tall [ __ ] plus i'll tell
you also we're a couple of hipster
whatever pretty boys that might whip
kojak's ass yes i know no it's a very
funny sketch though
it's a guy off broadway and he's uh he's
very funny we got 30 seconds or three
minutes all right we have to time down
in 30 seconds gay jared is producing
today and he's as you know it's a
nightmare so here here's what i want to
do i want to be very much on time i want
to give you guys which is funny you must
be the only on-time gay in the world
all right all right okay hold on we have
to go to a break here we'll come back
and then we'll talk politics we'll be
back with dean kane milo yiannopoulos
and gay jared will be fired louder with
crowder stay tuned
so glad to be back okay so we'll talk
politics because of an eclectic mix and
we were just talking about kojak and
dean kane doesn't like being called a
pretty boy i saw you an american
gladiator i get that you're an athlete
okay and uh having worked in the
entertainment industry i'm sure it must
bother you because
all of these actors here's my here's my
theory dean and then sorry sorry milo
and then we'll bring you on and talk
politics both of you here's my theory
dean i'm a pretty big guy right i'm
about six two two and a quarter oh wow
and um i've been on this yeah it's a d
for in hollywood i'm gargantuan you're
gigantori uh i was in a film called the
covenant where it was like chase
crawford stephen all these like the
pretty boys the cw pretty boys yeah and
um here's my 510 130 right yes exactly
and uh you know but they they got the
six-pack
now
all of these actors right they're giving
these these training tips and stuff
dean how co let's be honest steroids are
so common you were an actual athlete you
played football as a general rule though
hollywood consists of drama geeks only
now you have to turn drama geek into
batman it's like oh i can't do a push-up
but i have to be 220 within three months
how common are the steroids in the
industry because i know several people
who've done them
i don't know anybody who's dumb to be
honest real oh come on i really don't i
mean i i only knew like three football
players who did people keep something
about me they just keep the drugs away
maybe i just i frown upon them so
openly but so i've never i don't know
anybody who has i mean i look at
somebody like the rock and the way he is
jacked up so much and i think of course
he's probably got a little help and
that's too much and i just worry about
him in about 10 years um but other than
that i mean whether it's a little zac
afron who's you know as tiny as they i
mean he's tiny but yeah he's shredded
and ripped i don't know if these guys
are doing steroids so i really don't
have a clue i know i've never done it
that's that's for sure and i really
don't know anybody who has all right
fine there you go he's
the truth i mean i wish i could tell you
otherwise dean cain the politician let's
get into politics
let's get out of politics so dean you
said you're a libertarian last time you
were on and then we have milo who uh for
the record is super gay but is socially
more conservative
than you so
i'm really not that much of homosexual i
mean you know i don't even like them i
don't like them if i if i if i were
straight i would be the biggest
homophobe i swear
um you know like i don't even like them
very much um no no i don't find that
socially conservative i mean i know that
i'm not a libertarian because you know a
lot of my friends libertarians
especially
so many of my friends and colleagues
libertarians but i sort of think you
know it's all well and good until you
realize that you know actually be better
if your daughter did not grow up to be a
crackle um you know it's quite good so
it is quite good to enforce some
morality and maybe put incentives in the
tax system to encourage people to behave
well and you know the other thing about
libertarians is you know or on the whole
libertarians are such children they're
because they're obsessed with two things
they're obsessed with weed and hacking
and all they ever want to hear about is
like where the next eight is coming from
and edward bloody snowden um this is all
they have to talk about all he wants
about weed and hacking weed and hacking
i mean there's sort of perpetually
seventeen it drives me insane i mean
libertarianism is you know it's some
great intellectual
philosophical sort of history and
heritage of this movement classical
classicalism js mill and all the rest of
it and all they want to talk about is
weed and hacking i think it just tries
to up the wall because there's some
really useful and interesting things
that they could say about the proper
limits of government but they never do
i'm guessing that eugene is not obsessed
with weed or hacking but um you know but
this is but this is the impression i
always get libertarian
well that i think it may be a slightly
different definition in the uk or as it
is here or the way i look at it maybe
i'm just defining it differently because
i'm a very much a small government guy
um
wheat as far as i'm concerned legalize
regulate tax it i could care less i
don't smoke it my son doesn't smoke it
i'm a father of a 15 year old he is not
crap i thought you might say i'm a
father of 15. i was like
what that's entirely possible but not to
my knife watching him in the spandex i
knew that he would be fertile yeah dean
cain is so
so fertile you look at him wrong you get
pregnant sorry go ahead
you get twins uh you know it's uh it's
you know so i'm a big i'm a small
government guy uh i'm just socially a
little more liberal and that sort of
lines me up in at least in the in the
united states i believe more as a
libertarian but i'm i'm i'm more hawkish
when it comes to things dealing with the
military and foreign policy yeah then a
lot of libertarians and and so it's hard
to really define myself but but my views
socially tend to be very libertarian let
me ask you this because i find i think
this could be an interesting discussion
so you saw the you know the scotus the
same-sex marriage we're basically okay
it's across all states now right it's a
thing now my opinion again i have been
called a libertarian by conservatives
and by libertarians i'm called too
conservative um it seems to me that it
was going that way you had was it 37
states who were going that way or had
voted on it they had same-sex marriage
and now it seems like there's an
unnecessarily hostile environment toward
it because they feel like it was an
abuse of the courts as a libertarian
where do you line up do you think it was
something that needed to happen to the
court scene or you were the rather seen
at state by state and then milo we'll go
to you even though you're from the uk
but you could have an opinion on states
rights uh my my understanding of the way
the constitution is laid out that would
be a states right issue um
so i do feel like the the the
the
supreme court did um litigate from the
bench and and they i just don't know
that that's the right way to do it um um
not little game but i mean they actually
created a law from the bench and so
that's a bit of activist
court i don't agree with that so much
i'm completely for same-sex marriage
don't get me wrong um i have no problem
with it whatsoever um
but i do think that was a statewide
issue yeah milo
i'm more skeptical about same-sex
marriage mostly because i think it makes
homosexuals really boring i mean the
only good thing about being gay was you
know it was being able to sort of break
all the rules stumble out of a club
bleary-eyed at 4pm on a monday afternoon
and nobody could judge you um you know
there's a good thing about being gay
that's gay marriage they want to say
this is just society's way of
controlling dissident subcultures you
know they just want to sort of settle
down get a house and a car and adopt a
child and have a terrible nine-to-five
job become just like everyone else i
mean being gay you could grow up being
gay it's pretty awful it's pretty you
know it's confusing you feel you know
miserable half the time yeah i've never
been a victim of any sort of you know
unpleasantness but you know generally
it's not a sort of happy way to be your
reward for that is for the rest of your
life you get to behave terribly and
nobody can say anything um you know they
said gay marriage is incredibly
depressing i think it's awful for a gay
culture in general becomes so sort of
bourgeois and depressing and miserable
um you know so i'm not a fan of that my
my
thoughts about the us are that um what i
don't like
um is a sort of setting of minority
against minority in this case sort of
religious rights versus um versus
homosexuals and i think personally as a
gay man looking at what's happening in
the world today my view is that um sort
of leftist righteous um sort of lgbt uh
activists are now you know pretty much
speak with the voice and force of the
establishment and it's um people with
faith that have to um effectively in
some ways are the insurgents and have to
constantly reaffirm their rights and
constantly be vigilant about uh being
bullied by the media being bullied by
the establishments of all kinds and when
you see things like that memories pizza
um you know these these sort of poor
pizza shop owners who get uh hectored
and pilloried and bullied into closing
down their store because they don't want
to make a cake for lesbians i mean you
know who would endorse lesbian marriage
you know what you know what the domestic
violence rate is for lesbians i mean you
know this is i actually i don't even
crap out of each other no they beat the
crap out of each other all the time i
mean you know i can well imagine if i
owned a cake shop but i'm not making you
the cake you're just going to end up on
her face um no uh so you know but being
but sir seriously bullying you know
bullying these poor people who just you
know these reporters they go looking for
trouble they go searching around for
somebody who will you know if the call
around 50 people finally they find
someone in you know
what you would call
or whatever you know so some
middle of nowhere place where they
finally find somebody who will say no
i'm not comfortable with this and then
they pass them all over the media that
to me is is
the real issue in the real issue here is
that this is syndicated terrestrially
you are going to give us a lot of work
milo but i
it doesn't surprise me at all i i will
tell you this
look at the statistics on lesbian
domestic violence you can look up an
article that i wrote for breitbart which
is called attack of the killer dykes um
and basically you look i'm just making
your life worse now i'm sorry i mean
this is the name of the i'm just merely
quoting a piece of journalism for your
listeners um you know if you if you look
this up um
you know i i put all the statistics down
you know and it's the argument on gay
marriage whether it's lesbians or
otherwise is pretty much gone now pretty
done and dusted whether or not it's for
the supreme court to legislate or
whether it's a states rights thing seems
to me a secondary to what's happening in
society generally which is that the you
know the sort of anxious hand-ringing
pearl clutching white middle-class
bloggers who are setting minority
against minority from you know their
purchase at vox and buzzfeed and gawker
and advice and places like that um you
know pitting the religious against gays
pitting hispanics against blacks and
that for me the next the next 10 years
really of american politics is going to
be not just about men and women fighting
but about minorities in open warfare
with one another and the gay marriage
issue really is most interesting in that
respect uh the problem in the us is that
i think religious people are having
their rights trampled on every day um in
services this tiny minority you don't
even care that's a good point uh you're
far too salient points let's go back to
talking about bbc here's the deal um
well he made a big book yes yes yes yes
that's why they warned me he was smart
stephen
i don't yeah he doesn't know like three
of the words he said he has no business
being on this program at all it's it's
it's offensive really to our audience
what's funny is we're going to have
carly fiorina on like next week or the
week after it's just to follow this
that's what makes it such good watching
steven that's it or listening depending
on your listening
no i i agree and i i do appreciate you
know milo's point of view i think that
people's uh a lot of people just don't
know how to sort of package what you're
saying milo coming out of your mouth now
dean real quick because
you have those headphones and you got a
bunch of street cred last time we had
you on the show for those who are
listening terrestrially i mean these are
hardcore gamer headphones are you a
gamer i am a gamer my son is a big time
gamer so of course he's like that these
are the best headphones wear those and
i'm like oh okay um and yeah i'm a gamer
i play uh world of warcraft it's pretty
much the only game that and some call of
duty so have you been up to speed on the
gamergate issue because you know milo
was at the floor from this what is that
i don't even know what that is oh god
milo do we have time can we can we
i can summarize it as quick as possible
okay let's summarize i'm writing a book
on this i'm having to learn how to pitch
it really quickly um basically the
culture wars which we're familiar with
you know feminists and um you know uh
authoritarians of all stripes you want
to clamp down on creative freedom tell
people that art forms make people sexist
and violent and racist and all the rest
of it no evidence for any of this it's
all crazy finally these wars arrived in
video games last year and so um gamers
unlike any other fandom unlike comic
books fantasy sci-fi all of whom have
toppled over and taken it and started
self-flagellating about you know what an
awful diversity-less you know terrible
straight white male patriarchal kind of
pursuit this is gamer said you know what
actually no wait you're wrong about this
we're hugely diverse we're very
welcoming there is no evidence that
video games make anybody more violent
more sexist or anything else get out of
a get out of our hobby we're not
interested in your political warfare in
something that we love we
you know which we do precisely to escape
from this kind of nonsense in the rest
of the world and so that's basically it
it's a sort of pitched battle between
ordinary gamers on the one hand and on
the other um
you know the ranked masses of the media
all of whom bought this line about being
misogynistic losers um you know feminist
feminist sort of critics and academics
and uh you know basically the whole
establishment and on you know on the
virtuous side was
gamers and me and i was talking about
these guys from from sort of
august i think last year maybe september
um about you know that they're
adam baldwin adam baldwin came in and
was pretty big oh of course no but you
know but adam baldwin is like a hero
figure to these guys you know i think um
i think it was only sort of six months
later he decided you know what i thought
this i'm just going to get into the
trenches and really fight this with them
um you know
quite rightly he was a bit worried about
you know the allegations that were being
flung around um but of course hannibal
when there's uh the animal as uh
christian off some of the american
enterprise institute various other
people but yeah basically it was it was
you know you all know this dean is as an
actor as a as a hollywood guy you know
every once in a while somebody complains
about something you know this is sort of
sexist misogynist representation of some
realistic body all right we need you to
wrap it up just before we go to the
break summarizing quickly yeah i know
that's the problem with these you know
i'll tell you what i think i'm done i'm
sorry hello hold on you know what we're
going to go to a break we're going to go
to a break summarize it i promise okay
go ahead i'm completely on the gamer's
side 100 oh there we go
if only we could get david barayan's
louder with crowder go to the website
now because we're going to uncensored
web version for those of you listening
terrestrially stay tuned we are out in
uncharted territory and apparently this
is necessary when milo comes on as a
guest because gay jared is going to have
to hit the oh crap button multiple times
throughout that last segment
um
so for those who are still here so milo
was just describing gamergate so i'm
surprised dean
that you i guess
well i guess
with the comic-con thing maybe they
wouldn't have brought it to your
attention but adam baldwin got in a lot
of trouble even at an australian comic
con where some people tried to ban him
like it's that big of a deal now where
these gamergate social justice warriors
people you know they're turning on on
people like you so they can turn on me
all they want they can turn 100
because i have no qualms whatsoever i've
been playing games all these types of
games my entire life i've also shot the
real guns and done the real things and i
promise you as my son has there is no
correlation i don't buy it for a second
if somebody's predisposed to do
something the game is not going to kick
him over the edge if they watch grant
you know play grand theft auto it's not
going to work that way it's the
difference when you have a real weapon
in your hand or when you're really doing
something to somebody um i am totally on
the gamer's side if they want to throw
me under the bus or come at me go ahead
they're going to be very happy to hear
that my headline is going to read
superman supports gamergate um so you
know
they're going to be very happy to hear
that i'll put my
stamp of approval on it no doubt milo is
going to
chase you down like a gang from the film
warriors from 1979 oh it's gonna be a
pack of gay englishmen like instead of
the baseball furies and they're going to
come at you
just to take you out for a nice steak
dinner and most likely call you back
dean
perfect
i never call them back in the morning
don't spread scandalous lies
all right that is fair um okay so we
talked about that and then
let's go to this real quick because milo
is very interested in american politics
dean do you have someone who you're
you're favoring right now in this
presidential primary i gotta tell you no
it's really uh when there's 16 is it 16
candidates
republican
16 candidates for the republican uh uh
nomination there's three
are there three for the for the
democrats uh well it's clinton sanders
o'malley o'malley oh yeah who got in all
truth gotten all kinds of trouble for
saying all lives matters
that's a really controversial statement
i'm glad he apologized for that yeah i
i'll say all lives matter and i'm not
going to apologize oh well hold on gage
jared is chiming in al gore if he can
get away from the hooker's feet yeah
they're trying there's there's there's
some there's a crowd trying to push al
gore now apparently into the into the
race which they literally would have to
wheelbarrow him into the race push him
it's going to take a lot of effort
just push him there al gore wow yeah al
gore they're i won't well i was going to
compare him to someone else who's a
conservative there are few people
creepier who have been around than out
gore i'll buy that yeah he's a creepy
dude and it's by the way if we people
are going to throw in speculation here
you go milo you said you have the most
fantastic gaydar there is um people
threw around all the speculation that
rick perry was gay you know that was the
rumor that floated a little bit just
asking me to libel people now aren't you
yes yes i am
a much stronger defamation law in the uk
oh all right well okay you can just you
can just uh well i mean if you look at
sort of democratic candidates like jeb
bush no wait um you know i think if you
look at this
i don't know gaydar rick perry i would
say total homo um really no okay i
wasn't getting any rick perry now you're
going to i'll just say al gore i've
always thought al gore was gay oh no no
no no he's so unfashionable um no no
he has no personal style whatsoever
there's
nothing i mean you know rick perry's got
a certain swagger you know rick rickshaw
you can still help mike yeah maybe no
but al gore is way too unfashionable to
be homosexual we will not accept him we
will not have him he's not getting in
okay rejected let me ask you this this
has been my suspicion for a while milo
and yes we're totally we're totally
pigeonholing you here because you know
we have a we have a gay past hillary
clinton what do you think you think she
could uh do i think she's a lesbian yeah
oh well she's yeah you know what she's
got that sort of cold steel behind the
eyes that a lot of them have hasn't she
she's got the terrible is that the
devil's one size too small
you know do you know what i mean that
sort of dead fish eyes you know yeah or
maybe bird eyes they just
you know there's something something of
the ineffable the sort of endless abyss
behind those eyes of cold dark uh
sociopathy um and it's sort of easy
quite often in lesbians i don't know
maybe um we're allowed to say that we
hate each other don't let anybody ever
tell you that gays and there's like it's
like the jets and the sharks the
lesbians and the gays where this idea
ever came from gays and lesbians get
along we like each other we hate each
other um no uh vampires
um
is she a lesbian
if i didn't know anything about her and
i just saw her i would say yes
yeah i thought that was a very
reasonable suspicion for a long time and
i remember saying it at a meeting room
in msnbc and they were like shocked i
was like come on even if you don't think
it you can't be shocked you know like if
she were my neighbor and i moved in and
assuming i didn't know what a horrible
person she was to begin with i would be
friendly with her and i would like
tiptoe around like oh is she is she not
let's be careful
you know when we give her a housewarming
gift
yeah i mean yeah i know i mean the
lesbians and housewarming gifts always
very dangerous you know you give her the
verbena instead of the vanilla i mean it
is bad you just you'll end up served for
dinner you know
there are scary people here okay here's
something i wanted to talk about sorry
dean we're so sorry you dean such a nice
i'm enjoying this show that's fun um did
you guys see the run-in with ben shapiro
and the the [ __ ] on cnn transgender i
know he's a hater
zoe turd yeah yeah i saw that that was
funny actually it was very funny i
laughed i thought ben was hysterical i
mean
zoey grabbing him by the head by the
neck that's a sociopath uh yeah well
look
threaten me joey you know go ahead
threaten ben threaten me threaten
stephen crowder well that's that's what
i was wondering right it was a straight
threat i i it's a song
it's a salt
i was like you know what's worse about
it is i mean it's
and this is kevin mckinnis's point she
said uh you know cut that out sir you're
going home in an ambulance nobody goes
home in ambulances that's like
ambulance takes you home
takes you home something has gone wrong
you're gonna go home in a hurst little
guy
i mean it's kevin mccann's joke but it's
a good point
it's a good joke no it's a good point
and you know i it's funny because gavin
and i talked about this either a swan
die versus a belly flop and sometimes a
belly flop is necessary and i really
like ben i mean full disclosure i've
known ben for a long time and had him on
this show before it was even a show when
he was doing prom time propaganda but i
almost feel like
this is a this is a barbarian zoey and
it's not because zoe wants to be a woman
and i i won't accept that zoe is a woman
i don't care um it's because zoe is
threatening someone to put him you can't
be civil with a barbarian you know i
feel like it should have been a knock
the hand off the shoulder don't touch me
bobby instead of like oh that's
inappropriate um well that's why i said
if it was it was a stephen crowd or a
dean can you put his hand on it'd be a
different response yeah but zoey would
be charging me with assault that's the
problem right or me but that's
interesting
ben is a he's he's a very mental guy and
he and he went and he went
mental not quite mentally yeah are you
mental
i would have been awesome
well did you see zoey afterward uh but
here's the thing not apologize well no
not apologize but here's the deal i
admit to it i i saw something where he
admitted to it she whatever i don't know
yeah i know well you're gonna get flack
for that here's the thing
i don't know
the helicopter pilot that's where i knew
him until he assaulted
yeah ben shapiro well here's the deal
too okay um zoe afterwards on facebook
milo if you weren't seeing zoe blocked
me but every single thing zoe was
tweeting was like look who's trending on
facebook it's all about me
you know that kind of deal and
everything was like look i'm trending
i'm training and you could just and now
zoey is turning on bruce jenner caitlyn
jenner to get more air time the this is
someone who just craves attention
well you know some people say that the
transgenderism is um is a psychiatric
disorder that ought to be in the dsm
somewhere near for example bipolar and
narcissistic personality disorder yeah
um and they get very upset when you say
this but you know just look at the
prominent transsexuals and even if
they're not prominent if you happen to
know any personal life i mean i don't i
know one you know and tell me that they
don't have a touch of npd about them i
mean these you know these people uh have
a crave attention more than they crave
you know
surgery i mean it's it's it's an
extraordinary thing they do they do seem
broken that way what worries me more is
that we're creating this sort of
privileged class of victims i think in
america um where if you belong to a
particular group or you have a certain
disease you can basically get away with
saying anything i didn't find her threat
on the tv as shocking as i found her
agreeing with a um somebody on twitter
well let me say something you know what
i found shocking
you know what i found shocking
and this is what i would have done
differently and i think ben probably
handled it better than i would have but
when right away he's like well that's
mildly inappropriate and they go well
you used masculine pronouns basically
like right away no one like hey a [ __ ]
just assaulted a jewish lawyer on
television my reaction they're going
well you said he to someone who formerly
had a [ __ ] how dare you
she still got it i think she's still
here i don't think zoey does i know
bruce caitlyn does
that okay yeah caitlyn does it well it's
like 90 something percent of them don't
do it but she went on um i mean there's
a satirist a great satirist called
godfrey elf who's the sort of social
media satirist and he takes the piss out
yeah yeah feminist anyway he's
absolutely great you must follow him but
um he sort of he tweeted her to he likes
to go to let go sort of very left-wing
celebrities and pretending to agree with
their points of view so they sort of get
locked into conversation and then he
drops harm on them but um he he sort of
he referred to um ben shapiro as a
neo-nazi or president of supporters of
neo-nazi and she replied agree
i'm pretty sure when you had your hand
around his shoulder i saw your mocha um
if somebody else called a prominent
jewish journalist a neo-nazi i mean you
can't even imagine what the result would
be but this is an example
well you know what's funny though i will
say this
while we're on the threat of
anti-semitism um my dad when i said i
sent him a video my dad literally and my
dad is funnier than anyone who's on he's
just just brilliant he calls me up and
uh literally not even a hello let's go
hello he goes
that little jew's going to lawyer up man
but he knows ben too he was like oh man
that's all he said and you know listen i
mean it's just in bed would laugh if he
knew it obviously it sounds terrible out
of context but we were sitting and we
were just
falling over to just laughing it's like
this is here's the crazy thing about
we've talked about this
and this is something i've talked about
well you understand this dean because
you're a healthy guy and you're a big
guy right we avoid this there's this
whole gmo thing i've never heard anyone
else make this argument
let's just make a physiological
statement here okay we avoid gmos and we
want organic food people i don't but
most people do why a big part of it is i
want to avoid xenoestrogens which
basically mimic estrogen in the body
it's very cancerogenic it's very bad for
men to have higher than normal levels of
estrogen uh it's also very bad for women
to have higher than normal levels of
testosterone but not as toxic as
estrogen right that's a huge thing for
men's health it's very good for your
skin
uh actually no not for men it's not um
but here's the thing right so we we try
and do all that and we have to we want
the fda labeling we have the usda rights
we protest them no monsanto no gmos yet
when we're injecting actual estrogen
into a guy's ball sack uh we all turn a
blind eye and say well it's their choice
it's completely healthy i think that
people right now i mean statistically we
don't have long-term studies you are
going to put these people into a
shallow early cancerous grave and no one
wants to talk about that we know what
estrogen and hormones they'll never die
of cancer because they've all topped
themselves first i mean the johns
hopkins research approved they were the
first university to do this they know no
longer do the studies what it showed is
not only no improvement in suicide rates
post-surgery but most studies show that
more people commit suicide after surgery
than they would have done if they didn't
have it so they're not even going to get
to this i mean way before the you know
the cancer starts metastasizing they'll
already have hang themselves in their
living room so i don't think we need to
worry about cancer
well you can put that right now yeah
right now no but i mean dean you're
socially more liberal but do don't you
think we get to a point where it's like
ben said he said at what point am i
required to participate in in your
delusion did you see well see that's the
thing i support ben's right not to
participate 100
i personally if somebody wants to do
that go ahead right not my business rock
and roll if you want to hurt that
yourself or or do that to yourself or
change your i'm go ahead that's where i
leave you alone but don't make me
change my behavior be to to accommodate
yours well you played sports so what
about this what about you know like
fallon fox i've written about fallon fox
male to female transgender who now beats
the crap out of what's unfair no
period end of story not fair
and if a woman wants to change and and
become a man and come play football go
ahead yeah that's something you never
see though you know we've seen as you
get killed yeah i know it's it's one of
the you never see the female to male
transition in a contact sport it's
unfair the trajectory of pressure is
only ever and
the trajectory of pressure is only ever
in one direction and that's because for
example the same people who um want all
of women to be allowed into men's spaces
and want to be able to take over men's
sport are the same people who are
complaining that women's football is
less highly remunerated was less highly
remunerated because it's incredibly
[ __ ] dull uh enormously boring i
disagree with you i disagree with you
i hate soccer but i think soccer is a
woman's sport it's just the same as the
men so i it's it's a wash to me well
well i agree with you in general it is
it is a sport for girls um but you know
there are boy girls and girl girls and
the boy girls are faster and better and
they make more money and that's
perfectly reasonable but you know you
never never see people who want um you
know uh boys injected into girls sports
of course they of course they don't well
it's even funny you know at a local
grappling tournament there was this girl
who was looked like chaz bono was
clearly transitioning to become a man uh
i mean hormone had a little bit of peach
fuzz was clearly going through it yet
still competed as a woman at the
grappling tournaments and
it's not fair i mean
why because she who wants to be he knows
that she would be clobbered by men
here's and i've talked about this dean
and people get really mad again for
going to make the physiological argument
i'm a huge mma fan uh christian well uh
christian uh she used to be santos her
name they just call her cyborg now you
know she's the she's the 145 the 145
champion in the division where rousey
isn't fighting so she was in strikeforce
so milo i'll summarize this quickly for
you let me show you how one summarizes
quickly um and oh shut up the sci the
cyborg broad right just dominates women
just jump just wrecks them you know like
gorilla hulk smash
and it's not even close and the thing is
she got she was stripped of her belt at
one point because they found out at one
point in her career she had used
steroids okay
fallon foxes do steroids his whole life
they're called balls now let's say the
biggest juiced out like you're talking
about you know dean the rock or arnold
and his
okay okay okay okay okay okay arnold in
his prime he looks big arnold in his
prime who admitted to it right walking
human pin cushions let's say russian
athletes in the 60s or 70s let's just
use them or east german whatever yeah
exactly
them okay if a man is on steroids the
highest priced designer steroids humanly
possible they still don't enjoy the
hormonal advantage over me that i enjoy
over a woman as a matter of fact it
would probably tenfold more me to a
woman agreed and once you know about the
hockey thing right like the women's
the american women's olympic hockey team
plays high school hockey teams and loses
high school boys hockey teams and loses
they consider it to be really tough
preparation for the women for the
olympic competitions the women's olympic
hockey team play like high school boys
and and lose but they think that's
basically the best team they can find to
play against and that's a wrinkle it's
called testosterone it's a wrinkle yeah
but
i didn't believe that when i first read
it it's absolutely true oh it's
absolutely well and also listen when you
talk about women's hockey you're talking
about a rink full of hillary clinton's
if i've ever seen one
actually my wife is gorgeous and all of
her cousins look like her and they all
play hockey i was like are you are you
kidding me it's a non-contact version
though two women's hockey ah
you're not allowed to hit but you're
always why do you want to break that
face you know like what are you doing
this for you nothing you have nothing to
prove you're thin and gorgeous and
wonderful and you have all of the sort
of
social power you could ever want of
every man that you ever come into
contact with why do you do you having to
prove you don't need to hit this ball
into a just just just stay home that's
like why what just don't get out of bed
why are you doing this well that's an
interesting point i think one that is
missed on dean because he just has to
beat women off with a stick men do all
this stuff because eventually you know
they want to have sex you know like they
want to compete it's like look look i
put the ball through the hoop mate with
me yes exactly that's why that's a big
part of like testing yourself and
improving women don't have like women
don't have to be funny women don't have
to be good at sports we don't have to
have a lot of money because we want you
anyway
they don't know they don't have to do
anything i mean they don't even have to
work out these days um you know they
probably should um no it's perfectly
true i mean there's a reason why you
know sex is the reason we made it to the
moon sex is the reason we have the
internet sex is the reason that we you
know that that human civilization has
developed as it has and that's why men
do it and not women it's also entrenched
patriarchy and sexism men have the
competitive aspirational drive in them
because they want to have sex with more
women um you know that's why men build
go out and build things it's not because
they're you know sort of hangover
stereotypes from an older sort of you
know
heterogeneous oppressive era it's
because men want to have sex with women
so they want to impress them i mean
there's not this is not rocket science
or some sort of remarkable uh so
sociological insight but it's something
that is now completely taboo to to uh to
express anywhere in the media in america
today yeah well dean doesn't understand
it because he would just have to walk
out and go you you you
uh i mean i'll be i'll full disclosure i
i want to have sex with women i'm just
going to throw it out
well
this is the internet so this is the
right place
we can find you many suitors my son is
15 so i clearly have had sex at least
once at least once this is true oh you
broke him he broke my heart
milo was just hoping i was sure he was a
hummus i mean did you see that outfit i
mean did you see the outfit and come on
terry hatcher is a gay guy's idea of
what a beautiful woman is like
she's absolutely beautiful but if a gay
man was after defense gay man was asked
to describe the most beautiful woman in
the world he would describe terry i mean
you know that's that's that's what he is
she has so many gay fans from from
desperate housewives they're all
homosexual so obviously you know the
outfit the spandex terry hatchery
my early my teenage gaydar was not as
refined then as it is now
yeah well i guess that's
that just sort of is something you know
we've talked about listen i'm a
christian i'm a conservative and so you
know where i line up on like the
same-sex marriage issue as a societal
you know societal ramifications but i've
also sort of broken with a lot of
christians where i think people have
listen people have sexual proclivities
just like you know i prefer blondes to
brunettes um and i just even was
thinking about it you know i was
watching lois and clark
looking at terry hatcher milo was
watching new adventures of superman
looking at team king
something for
everybody that was why was such a good
show i mean you know
it was it was oh you know i had got my
sort of sociopathic doc kind of destroy
the world urges out with with lex luthor
the guy who said lex luthor's name i
always forget it was terrific um
that's the one um you know and he really
like he was so good in that role i mean
just magnificent um pro probably the
best lex luther you know um and and so
no it was a great show had some
something for everybody and of course it
was about you know it was set in english
paper so it was perfect for me yes well
also of course dean cain has done much
more than a superman we don't want to be
those people who like what was it like
doing that at one time but it doesn't
never bother me at all
if i stopped working if i wasn't working
that'd be a problem but i'm fine full
disclosure dean okay you don't have to
answer this do you have the kind of
screw you money or if you never want to
do anything again you wouldn't have to
absolutely not
really well
if you're listening to this and you have
a commercial for toothpaste in japan i
am there
i'd be there faster than you could sign
the contract really no um
that kind of money i mean if i sold all
my assets sure
but uh i've got a lot of assets so i
want to keep those up and going so no i
don't have that kind of money yet right
well i always because you know a lot of
people have sort of mis these they have
these misconceptions about what people
make in the entertainment industry
sometimes and there are some people you
know who are ringing that register
really highly but tv too i mean
obviously listen you you weren't begging
on the street you were paid well but tv
has the salaries have just skyrocketed
like in the last decade but i think you
have kids growing up now who don't
really realize that for a long time
they're sort of this division right and
now it's like i mean you have i mean
these salaries you see in tv are just
unreal it first started the first one
was friends right wasn't it one of them
was being paid a million an episode all
of them ended up at a million episodes
yeah holy crap yeah but you know that's
the funny thing is we were shooting on
the warner brothers lot we were there
for a full year and then two new shows
came and bookended us on the stages one
of them was called er and the other was
called friends and both of those shows
just went berserk after a year and we
were always there before them
and we were there after them they'd come
in they'd shoot they'd leave we're still
there we it was it was grueling what we
were shooting on lois and clark and we
didn't quite enjoy the popularity they
did it was kind of especially those guys
coming for friends they would come in
i mean we were there for seven hours
before they showed up and they'd come in
do a read through work out the gym and
leave
i was like that's the job i should have
had
they were
matthew perry was talking about what
you're taking in front of
which role uh
you know it wasn't written you know
there was nothing in there i could do
those guys were fantastic matt leblanc
originally was like supposed to be the
hot sexy dude and then they just saw how
funny he was and he became joey because
if you watch the early version yeah it
was it it had to find itself but matt's
listen those guys it was a great show
great run i don't i don't begrudge
anybody their their high salaries at all
i just begrudge your bs story there's no
way matthew pray was working out at the
gym yeah he wasn't in there you're right
and you know who's in there a lot back
in the day was mcconaughey you know what
conor hey i met mc well i i okay i
walked across him once my brother
actually spent some time with him in ut
because he's an austin guy
you don't really like you could even
this is when he was like working out not
like now like you know aids matthew
mcconaughey dallas buyers club uh i mean
pre-aids
he
for a role i mean i don't know he could
have daniel day-lewis he could be method
acting we don't know
the early stages early i mean not right
up there early stage of 80 great you
know like you lose all your body fat
because attention and presence is
fantastic you know there's nothing
nothing not to love about the first six
months but after that yeah you end up
looking like mathematics yeah and it
ends up being pretty rough and you look
like jared leto but my brother was there
and you could fit him in your back
pocket he's not a big guy but you know
what i mean no dean it's like it's not
like like he's not particularly short
it's just very finely featured
just like a lot of actors are just very
you just bird bones just sort of small
and that's people don't realize that's
why they look so big on camera because
for example arnold was never that strong
for his size he had small joints so
large muscle bellies so at 230 he looked
massive yeah he's not that he's small
he's shorter than i am what are you six
one six two i'm six
really he sure my dad met him a long
time ago back when he was just
bodybuilding he said he was like yeah
six foot he's probably drunk he's
probably struck a little that just has
to happen as we age but yeah he's he's
not that tall he was depositing his his
powers into that ugliest maid who ever
lived and it just drained him
we're simple creatures ben you know what
i mean you hang around long enough
yeah but why i mean why would he risk it
for like literally
actually i mean you know when you spend
a lot of time with a lot of different
men
um you realize you realize men are
basically you know very very easy to
deal with and
fundamentally all the same women you
know can be very different women can be
very difficult different and difficult
to figure out and women can be you know
very very mystifying and and uh and well
maybe i would think that but you know
men basically all the same
hold on you know what you know why he
did that
why because she was there
yeah i guess it makes sense hold on a
second gay jared wants to say something
something this guy called bs here
because because dean imdb says list five
eleven and a half oh are you one of
those guys who's five eleven you say six
oh no i was measured in buffalo at six
at five eleven and five six when they
measured in the nfl so i was one-sixth
of an inch short now hey listen i may
have shrunk i don't know it's possible
okay
different product they've been fried in
the hair get some putty you can pull oh
hey because i see your hair is kind of
popping up there crowder i see i can
throw it up a little bit but i can't get
here i'm six too easy yeah well you know
it's funny i was six i mean i'm like
high end 62 more more really six three
when i was measured but i have two
herniated discs now and that'll take you
down a little bit um but yeah still i
mean listen six foot what are you two
two fifteen two twenty yeah so we're
about the same you're a little more
compact you have some samoan in you
don't you're just asian uh japanese but
i i'll play someone for the right price
get off my get off my beach buddy
hey bro this is our surf cove that's
pretty much every samoan roll
and then they have you come in if you
like when they're protesting a non
redhead playing little orphan annie
hey we don't know a lot of rolls out for
his brother
i'm sorry milo you have to do some bbc
thing right you have to let you go you
have time
yeah i i will actually probably in the
next 90 seconds something like you said
so um i've completely gone right there's
probably a car waiting somewhere oh yeah
i do actually all right well listen okay
we'll keep dean on because uh uh he
doesn't have to go to the bbc and we'll
wrap it up with him where you you know
where he doesn't have to feel so
uncomfortable because you're clearly
undressing him with your eyes milo where
should people find him you can't tell
you can tell because i'm on a phone in
today so you have no idea how lascivious
i could be naked i could be touching it
but i'm not just so you know
just i'm not doing any of those things
thank you stephen for setting this up
and uh it's awesome to speak to you dean
thanks so much both uh thanks guys oh
thank you very much i'm following milo
now though okay there you go all right
how can you follow him you were finished
yeah that's right where are you where do
people follow you milo because it's not
your name so where do people where do
people best find oh well i've i've named
myself on twitter as my favorite roman
emperor who was you know his only
failing was all of the all that burning
christian stuff but otherwise he was
great uh it's nero um so you can follow
me at nero or milo.nbc on facebook which
you'll have to copy and paste from
somewhere possibly from the description
below this video yeah uh and yeah
and uh yeah and look out for my comments
on breitbart and my book about gamergate
comes at the end of the year and that's
pretty much me thanks so much thank you
so much milo jared gay jared hang up on
you guys and uh all right dean
when you're watching this if you want me
to write a little uh endorsement of
gamergate i'm all on your side 100
well i'm i'm going to take you up on
that i'll dm you later done
thanks guys this is what happens see the
show starts off as a legit show and it
becomes just a pickup bar that's it
not only that but we just ended dean
kane's career by by outing him with a
gamergate supporter i'm happy
all right all right
we're hanging you out
bye
guys bye lovely champ isn't he dean he
is he actually he is extremely smart and
witty and uh i'll go on with him anytime
yes well any depends where he's going
you don't want to go yeah i mean i'll go
on the show with him yes he'll go on the
show with him any time
i go anywhere with him he's all right in
my book that started as funny there was
a rumor that started that i remember
that i was gay because i was with well i
don't want to adam but he's another
conservative who's who's openly gay he
doesn't talk about it a lot and so i
went with him in new york to like
like a gay bar it was like a gay
nightclub it was just a place where i
mean i lived in chelsea and so this
rumor came out that i was gay and i was
like i'm like man okay well if you lived
in chelsea you're gay right yeah well i
was the only my roommate was she's
awesome uh no listen at that street
whatever no no chelsea in in new york
sorry in chelsea new york city that's
what i'm talking that's what i'm talking
about i like chelsea yeah
um yeah that whole thing i mean
sometimes you have to remind people that
being gay means you have sex with men if
you're if you're a man so that that's
the thing that sometimes surprises
people they're like oh when i was doing
superman they saw me in the boots and
the cape and they were like well you
have to be gay and i was like well that
requires having sex with men and that's
not what i do but that's
what you know you don't you don't have
to write it off completely
hey listen not for your fans here just
leave it open to the imagination
ambiguous yeah it's leaving them 15 year
old son oh yeah that's true well you
know god gives it away yeah i guess well
you never know i mean david bowie did
mick jagger right
well that was the rumor i i thought you
know i don't know if it was wow you
never heard that rumor
ascribe too much uh validity to rumor
well imagine being his son at the lunch
table
well yeah yeah that's a topper if
anything that kind of wins that's a
fireman oh my god david bowie
we won't get thank you
so listen you actually you don't let
yourself go like a lot of people who are
sort of you know heartthrobs a lot of
like it seems like how will you can i
see 49 friday oh wow congratulations
what day is this airing
uh friday it's my birthday
it's your birthday happy birth you sure
it's not 50.
uh it's 50's coming around listen i'm
not missing i'm not miss counting i was
born in 1966 i'm taking 50. i'll be
better in 50 than i am 49 i promise you
that without a doubt is it just the
asian skin dealer do you like
microdermabrasion do you do some botox
the asian thing helps plus you know i
just don't do drugs i don't jerk around
i mean i'm a pretty straightforward guy
i work hard i raise my kid and hang out
with my family and i don't i don't do
anything that's going to
impact me really terribly and i go to
the doctor and get regular checkups and
i'm just a regular dude yeah my dad
doesn't get regular checkups just two
weeks ago i got cancer
oh you you did no my dad you're dead
that's no my dad had cancer but he's not
my biological father so yeah there's no
hereditary danger but uh why the hell is
gay jared laughing at cancer what's
wrong with you why are you laughing okay
i see yourself literally you brought
cancer into
this conversation just dropped it
cancer as well and survived that so yeah
i know he's fine they cut it out it was
uh it was a aggressive form of melanoma
and um people got offended because that
same week we had people sending their
best cancer jokes
and you should be able to joke about
anything yeah i know well especially i'm
like well i have a cancer pass my dad
has it
i mean people got so offended uh well
people can get offended no matter what
but that's that's the wonderful gift of
satire this is true let me ask you
something okay and then we'll go back
and then i'll let you go um what do you
like what are you what's your training
regimen like now what do you do to stay
in shape well i'm actually trying to
start a train a little bit now just
because uh
you know being a dad and my biggest
problem is i have psoriasis so i have
psoriatic arthritis now that is a
problem that's an aggressive disease
that goes after your joints that would
be days i would wake up where i was just
like something was swollen an ankle and
knee or whatever it's debilitating so
that's the problem i've been fighting
for the last 10 years and i've been
fighting it's been hard and i've been i
still be able to work i didn't know that
came from psoriasis because i have some
pretty bad joint problems and um i've
always got the dry patchy skin in the
winter but i don't know if that's
psoriasis i have psoriasis full-blown it
was all over my head it was on my arms
things i had to take medication for that
but what it's become more now is i'm
working with a group called the beverly
hills rejuvenation center and i'm
balancing my hormones because they were
all jacked up and that has
my psoriasis is
90 better i don't take any enbrel or any
or those things anymore i had to take
for a couple years stuff like that to
attack it and the reality is it
balancing my hormones is changing
my life how do they do that do they do
it like holy basil or something do a
full you do a full blood workup and they
check out what you're what you're
missing what things are up you know what
vitamins and things and there's it's a
whole it's a whole you know a large
encompassing
program that they have and it's just for
me specifically it's been phenomenal
i've been doing it for a couple months
now and i feel
85 better was your thigh right off my
thyroid is perfect my brother's thyroid
was jack but that's another story yeah
that's me too well i was because i was
wondering when i went in and you know i
had some issues at one point it was a
big part of was just stress i just don't
cope with stress a lot of go go and then
burn myself out i'm sure you probably do
the same then you're running on
adrenaline and that that's a hard thing
cortisol
yeah and then you have yeah it's amazing
to do this and you know i vitamins and
things that i i am feeling a thousand
percent better and i'm able to work out
again i just i literally just started
working again working out again last
week are you doing just basic compound
lifts
real simple no that no pain on the
joints even the shoulder work and
there's no way i could injure myself at
a certain point you know i played
football forever and you get injured
yeah and so for anybody you know in
their 30s 40s go you know you're not you
don't have to
deadlift 900 pounds and you know there's
no need for that sort of thing that
you're you're not competing um in the
nfl so you you do things for strength
and for you know endurance and just for
your overall health and so i'm learning
how to work out smarter and easier yeah
it's true i mean
i i don't i'm sure i mean you were an
elite
athlete i was never you know i i got to
a point we had mark riptoe on who's a
strength coach you're at starting
strength and i got to a point like a
recreational total about like 1200
pounds and i was able to deadlift 450
squat about 420 something and at that
point my bench was never super high now
it'd be over 300 but i'm just long arms
so that's like a recreational total it's
nothing like you would find in the nfl
but um for me that was really big with
small joints and there's only so long
right you can you're redlining that
engine
and then it just takes a toll yeah it
takes a toll and it's it's like you have
to decide between
optimal performance for a short amount
of time or longevity and uh sometimes
it's too late where you're like man my
back's never coming back the right way
ah but i don't think it is too late
sometimes because i was starting to feel
that way and then this is changing the
way i feel so i don't know watch me in
the next year and then and we'll discuss
this and then that'll be that'll be the
next big push they'll be like wow
he's in a lot better shape what happened
you know what we should do is we should
get you uh you know my dad is probably
jujitsu competitive he's 50 just had
cancer just had it cut out uh 54 and he
hasn't had a point scored against him
we should have you and him like do a
session where he teaches you some
grappling and just you know two uh two
you know you're almost 50 he's past 50.
just as an inspirational deal or people
like hey look i don't have to be a fat
piece of crap at that age exactly but
he's going to whip my ass yeah he i mean
very few people he wouldn't know that we
scored on him i wrestled in high school
so i know some some some wrestling yeah
sort of style wrestling but that ain't
the same thing well still that is very
very useful a lot of people don't
realize i mean the number one base you
can have in any kind of combat sport is
wrestling and to be fair my dad has um
we're very old school with brazilian jiu
jitsu i'm sure you're probably familiar
with it but it sort of evolved into a
hyperly technical sport and we're both
old school in that we always worked on
solid takedowns and basic control stuff
that would work in an actual altercation
so he has good takedowns probably not as
good as definitely not as good as a
collegiate wrestler anything like that
but you have a base and if you did that
you'd have some body awareness uh listen
he goes take me down i i'm going to
sprawl and i'm heavy
well he's he's uh he's more of a judo
guy it's a lot of clinch takedowns i
hate clinches yeah he's we actually have
a damn it feels good to be a gangster we
have like a montage of him and his jiu
jitsu tournaments and doing this lifting
stuff he's he's like why did you put
that out why did you put that out on the
internet like this because it's awesome
because it's awesome oh all right oh
okay do it you're 54 and that's how it
should be well he had his groin ripped
off the bone
you know what happened uh do you so do
you know are you from jiu jitsu what
guard is the guard position it's
basically like you're a shark sure yeah
you're on your back with your legs
around the guide so that you can still
submit a guy like he's gracie right
absolutely yeah you can do it so when
you're talking to triangle you can do
all kinds there you go there you go i
pay a lot of attention okay so this is
what happened i remember we had a guy
i'll just use his name he's
we'll call him i will call his name i
cause his name started with an i
uh yeah rhymed with ian so he was out
there and he was he's a very nice guy
but he was always very he was new and he
was very uh spazzy you know pretty
strong and so we're doing his guard
passing drills so we're doing is a guard
break in a drill yeah and a drill so
what's happening is you know the guy's
in you're in his clothes guard i'm
trying to describe it for people who
don't know because people are going yes
it's boring but you put your hands in
the hips and you stand up and you uh
break open the guard to that point so
you have leverage right so you put one
down you keep your elbows in so you
don't get unbarred and then you pass so
my dad at this point already had an
injured groin pulled and you know how it
is if you play football you have to be
aware
and uh so at this point i'm like hey dad
you know you probably said this out i'm
very protective of him and he's like no
no i should be fine so he turns to this
guy he goes hey listen you know for the
drill just just get up easy yeah he goes
i'll i'll open the guard and just do the
pat let's just do the passing don't do
the guard break because my guy goes oh
yeah yeah sure uh the timer gets set
the guy literally
and i hear
peppa pop crack
and i look over and my dad just like
sitting there like not crying but the
eyes are just watering like he's been
hitting the nose just like holding it
and so i went over to this indian market
next door and got some ice um and then i
choked the guy pretty bad because
you know
you have to as you should yeah but it
was it was in a match you know i didn't
choke him unconscious but i was like i
held it a little bit longer because he
was warned you should have yeah
unconscious you should have probably
well he's a nice guy but he's ripped my
dad's groin
i'm probably gonna choke you unconscious
yeah well he just wrecked the guy after
that when he recovered he's just i mean
he's bigger than me so he probably walks
around about like 2 30ish and uh 6-2 you
know played hockey at u of m uh athlete
so a real athlete guy yeah still he
should have known better yeah that did
your dad have to get that surgically
repaired or no i don't i mean i don't
know if it was torn off i should say
that was exciting all i know is it was
like blue and purple almost all the way
down to his knee that's the problem so
but he just didn't do anything for a
long time and we do a lot of like like
right now i have a pretty serious back
injury so i haven't known you just in a
few months but every day i'll get on the
well you probably know the airdyne if
you wrestled i get on the airdyne and
just mentally i go through positions and
literally just mentally treat it like a
grappling session every single day and
it's a lot mental yeah yeah do you find
that when you when you were away from
training were you thinking about it as a
guy always i always thought it was like
daydreaming i was everybody's like oh i
have to visualize visualize i was like
daydreaming i'd be sitting in class
listening to music or something like
that or you know i was a very quiet guy
pre-game but i was just running through
everything in my head i was daydreaming
i guess i was visualizing i called it
daydreaming i was sort of seeing a play
that i know was coming stepping in
making the right play doing all those
same same things the right move the
right position the right reads and i ran
that over my head but i wasn't taught to
do that it just naturally came to me but
that visualizing that because that's the
next thing you you visualize you you're
used to it you're ready for it you it's
not a surprise when it happens that's
the same thing with every move you're
going to find in wrestling yeah that
makes a lot of sense but you couldn't
were you
did you know what was coming with
american gladiators because i don't
think people expect that not at all you
don't know anything about what you're
going to do no i mean did you know that
you were going to be really good and
just people just kind of like oh you
know clark kent
because you i mean you wrecked that i
ruined my ankle three days before that
happened i just i've had i've since had
it surgically repaired but i couldn't
walk the day before the competition
so i promised you i would erect that a
lot more had i been able to walk but uh
do you have a cortisone injection pardon
me
nothing nothing nothing at all have you
seen this kid hadn't taped it up okay
jared hasn't seen this yeah it's it's
like viral now it's a stuff of legend
jean king went into american like
celebrity american gladiator and i mean
he was the best ever ever like he just
just wrecked the course these big
muscle-bound guys who are probably doing
juice some of those guys
they're like ah i'm gonna block you and
dean kane just like nope and just just
geeked them out you've not seen this no
but it sounds like you didn't gain them
do you still get letter you must get
letters about that i do you know what's
really funny i i get people who mention
it it's funny my sister went to that and
loved it she said it was so exciting
it's insane it was more exciting than
any of my football games it was just
this you're because everybody's packed
on top you like a high school basketball
you know gym or something so everybody's
there it was a lot of fun and it was all
in good fun and it was i enjoyed the
heck out of it but you know it's the
funny thing is that that things can go
viral now they can be on and be seen um
i always forever people were always
saying well i heard you played football
and you were a good football player and
i couldn't find anything on the internet
any game or anything so my buddy of mine
just did it this week is he edited
together um we had one little highlight
tape from my senior year of the whole
school of the whole you know season for
the for each game was sort of broken
down to a few plays and then uh one
televised game and he edited that into
something i just posted it on youtube
and uh so if you want to know if any
what kind of a college football player i
was
then because everybody's like you played
the nfl how did you do that well that's
how i did it so there's now a highlight
sort of set to music thing for of the
football days which should should beat
the tar out of that gladiator's tape
okay okay i'm sorry he probably gotta
watch this he's like that's not my best
foot forward gladiators here's the real
that was so much fun but the thing is
most people who like you're not going to
get tom cruise competing in american
gladiators you're not going to get a lot
of people competing because they're
afraid to compete because they don't
they don't think they're going to end up
looking good yeah it destroys the facade
yeah i would be a terrible honestly i
found i was a terrible uh athlete
horrible i mean i was just i was so
skinny and like it took me a long time
to grow until i found um and even then i
shouldn't want to consider myself i'm
you know a hobbyist who's pretty good um
i grew up way later and then the combat
that just grappling was just sort of the
thing where it was like it was the one
sport where everything just fit but
basketball i think my son might be there
is he that kind of a guy well he's just
starting to get into it he's also 15 and
he's 6-1 185 pounds just a big old dude
who really doesn't know how to do ever
he hasn't grown into it even when he
starts running it's all a little bit
awkwardy and he just hasn't grown into
that body yet and it's still growing i
mean the kid sleeps 15 hours a day but
gosh he's 15. i'll tell you what when i
graduated high school i was young i was
16. i graduated and i i listed six one
like 160 and i was lying by like 20
pounds
when i competed in judo my senior year i
competed in the 144 division and i
weighed myself with a a juice box in
hand
and um it's funny yeah that's that's
actually a story what happened that was
my the first time i ever competed i
didn't i was a jitsu guy and there
weren't any tournaments back then and i
wasn't ranked there was like a grappling
club for troubled kids at school and i
was like a trouble i wasn't really a
troubled kid because i came in like well
this is your what does your dad beat the
[ __ ] out of here something like no no
i'm just here because like i just wanted
to there was no like oh okay
and i was like kind of okay but i wasn't
great and then i was like well let me go
into judo and there's this crazy
romanian communist who taught me and
he's like well go compete so i don't
really know the rules in judo at this
point i'm thinking jiu jitsu right where
i'm just trying to drag a guy down and
choke him and um
what it was was you know there's
something called ipan which is if you
throw someone hard on their back it's a
clean throw it's like a knockout so i
didn't even know that and i go into the
tournament and the first thing is like
this guy comes just charging ah and i
just trip him and throw him like
harlow's back and then they call it but
i'm choking him
like okay so then the next one happens
i'm like oh okay so this is the rule so
the match two and i was like i was maybe
a yellow or orange this guy was like a
green because there weren't enough
people and um i remember the one thing i
was always good at was i'm very good at
pulling so i just pulled him in in a
clinch and i accidentally pulled him and
we headbutted
and he went sleepy no it was the
opposite i remember
i remember he literally he got
headbutted and then he goes i remember
his reaction clear as day he goes
and then the ref's like hey are you okay
okay okay he's like bleeding from his
nose and then he comes back like looking
like and i'm like oh my gosh this guy's
gonna be really mad he's gonna kick my
ass
and i threw him
but the fight went
he went went in a little puddle on the
floor his fight was gone but i remember
was so weird
i was like you're a fifth it was six i'm
like you're a sixteen he's like no
that goes back to the mike tyson comment
everybody has a plan until they get
punched in the face yeah but he was
furious though but your son you know the
good thing about jiu-jitsu
is
and i think this is what it was for me
you can adapt it to your body type you
don't have to be a specific you know if
he's tall and lanky he can be flexible
you know you have you have world
champions in every division in different
body types different skill sets it
always helps to be strong and powerful
it always helps to be athletic but you
know you have some people who are not
super quick like roger gracie is the
best jiu jitsu guy ever ever ever ever
ever horrible in mma that gracie name oh
yeah but he's a great
yeah horrible in mma but great in jiu
jitsu um and his he literally he choked
out everyone at the world i think it was
seven people with the same submission
and it's the submission you own a white
belt the most basic one and all he would
do is he would just lock you down get
slowly reverse you get to mount and
cross collar choke you and he's not
particularly athletic he's strong enough
but he's just tall and he's able to use
his leverage properly and it's like in
no other sport can a guy like that
do that and be world class you know and
then you have probably guys like you who
are very athletic or you know skipping
around and doing all the moves but uh
but you got your son in it i'm going to
actually boss rooting has a gym yes
right near my son's school and uh we're
signed up there i'm paying for it we're
not currently going because i got to get
the kid on the right program but it's
summertime it's tough but uh he's
promised to go ahead and go in there and
he went in one session was kicking
kicking kicking came out we stood up for
a second kid kicks me in the thigh boom
and i was like
okay
you can't kick me like that and
literally my leg went yeah i'm like well
i was like okay well you have a strong
kick but please don't do that anymore if
we're gonna goof around but i mean like
strong so i know he has it in him and i
if i wanted to get committed to that
he's discovered girls now so now he
wants to get now but so now he wants to
get jacked
right just to that and i'm like if you
want to do that get great of shape just
go do this and then you're in good shape
yeah that's just a little weight lifting
yeah
just even the training body trait for
him to sit there for an hour and kick or
whatever he's doing he will you know
because he's 15. he's got all that stuff
flowing through him he'll be
in great shape in no time he's 15. i
always wonder like do you do you feel
like um like you don't want to shake his
hand
because like
he's 15 you're like
no way you got to be careful you're like
oh you're at that age where just don't
[ __ ] when he closes the door
i don't care if he's in the bathroom for
an hour and a half or whatever that was
a
there's a new movie with vince vaughn no
one saw it and he was he walks in on his
son
and the door's closed he's like listen
okay i going not
just it wasn't a available movie but you
know vince vaughn is one of those guys
who can enter in a scene just
talk for half an hour and it's
hysterical yeah i know i i but uh yeah
that says
my son closed the door it's his time and
it's just he and ice i'm a single dad i
don't have to know what's going on i'll
go to the other side of the house just
put on those
headphones and yeah i don't want your
thumbs or anything i don't want to hear
anything no
hannah davis in his room now
who knows
hannah davis the she was on the cover of
sports illustrated
i don't know i don't know who that is
hannah davis she's she's pretty yeah
well i would assume so except uh the
only one the only one who is not pretty
on the cover of sports illustrated is
gonna sound terrible and okay don't say
this is a racist thing people okay
it was not the original shoot but the
tire banks reshoot of her sports
illustrated cover i don't know if you
saw that i don't recall okay so this is
what happened
she was the first black swimsuit model
uh on the cover sports illustrated
beautiful photo very beautiful woman now
it's no secret that tyra banks's weight
has fluctuated ah
and then in for black history month
she's like in honor of black history
month i am going to recreate the photo
shoot of the first black woman on the
cover sports illustrator i was like oh
my gosh that's great it was me
she just redid the photo shoot i was
like what is this so i guess it's more
so the attitude that made it
unattractive
but you're doing an homage to yourself
with yourself with yourself i'd be like
dean kane saying in honor of the
original superman i am going to put on
the team and again yeah well you know
what uh i am playing supergirl's dad in
the news of the new supergirl series i
do play her her father i can't talk
about
i just i play her we should have led
with that
well you know we can get back there
we'll bring milo back it'll technically
i have no idea
well we started shooting that it started
the shooting i mean they started
shooting now so um i feel so bad because
i'll be honest i kind of trashed the
trailer for that no go ahead everybody
has an opinion i love the trailer so
shame on you
but she is fantastic she seems good she
is she's she's so likable and she's got
that
that sense about her it's not ego it's
it's just excitement and positivity
she's going to be a superstar and she's
great well the reason i trashed it
though was because there was some it was
either vox or buzzfeed
who was like they were there was it came
on the heels of the black widow thing
like so here's the strong feminist hero
and my angle was like actually if you
watch this trailer it's kind of like
let's bake cookies for the boys like
it's kind of like it really wasn't like
you know what they were talking about
with black wood i don't know what it was
i remember watching it going like why
isn't why isn't buzzfeed talking about
this i'd have to go back and read it but
it was a feminism angle because they
were all over the black widow thing you
remember that where i don't i don't
recall it at all
jeremy renner said they were like who's
black widow in a relationship with was
that a president no he said yeah she's a
[ __ ] that thing well she's a [ __ ] yeah i
i heard that i don't i don't i don't
even recall that but i mean i don't know
how that even fits in but i'll tell you
it's this thing because they were all
mad they're like oh so we're all female
superhero [ __ ] i was like no and then
this supergirl thing came out and i was
like listen
i have i can't not have an opinion you
say that's because i hate female
superheroes so is that jeremy renner was
getting all this flack and by the way
black widow was a total [ __ ] she slept
with everybody right there you go
sometimes you gotta call you know a
widow a widow
but supergirl is is pretty female
empowering the show is very female
empowering and it's gonna be good all
the all the because she's she's so
positive and it's such a great it's got
it's got that sense of humor and that
sense of fantasy and romance that lois
and clark had yeah the current superman
film certainly is way darker and doesn't
have any romance or any humor though the
last one that came out with henry cavill
yeah i know i tell you what um
everyone's just like really looking
forward to batman vs superman and then
i'll i know it's going way too long i'm
gonna let you go but batman versus
superman did you watch the trailer i did
not see the trailer i i don't don't bs
me you have a google alert set for that
i will i'll watch it after we talk but
uh um i didn't see it listen i hope it's
great i hope i hope henry's a nice guy
ben is a good guy and i know him both i
hope it's fantastic but
um
if it was really batman vs superman it's
a it's a two minute a two second short
batman superman
yeah i know put some fish through his
chest and it's done
uh i think he has like an iron suit
oh really in the preview by the way
i i bet it it better be lead instead of
iron because if it's iron he's gonna
punch right through it anyway
really it's lead it's lead they caught
well only he can't see through lead you
know superman can't see through lead i
don't know what an iron shoot would do i
don't i think he'd just rip it there'd
be a little human appendage inside of it
like
bacon wrapped shrimp just in the eggs
nice
yeah i haven't seen it but i'll watch it
and i will have a an informative it just
looks like you said it just looks
completely humorous uh i'm sure it is
yeah i like the humor the guardians of
the galaxy phenomenal i thought it was
great hysterical that sense of humor has
to be in there um in my opinion right
no you're absolutely right and um
yeah it's a it's it's i don't know gay
jared like loved it he was just going
gaga over the trailer and my thing was
maybe he's a little dark yeah kj is a
little dark you have a dark side to you
i mean i don't like to blast it out
there and promote a bit it's it's true
there's there's a blackness there's a
blackness in his heart that can only be
filled with men named lyle you're off um
the point is like if you if you watch it
okay did you ever see the watchmen
yeah little bits of pieces i i didn't it
didn't appeal to me no i it was honestly
like to me was unwatchable that's why i
didn't watch it yeah i couldn't i
couldn't do it i could not do it now the
dark knight i think is one of the best
films ever and that was dark but it was
done in a way
yeah great story it fit yeah the
watchmen and i you know i was like who
have you read the comics like well i did
dabble in the comics and that's kind of
what this looks like batman versus
superman really really dark everything
is cgi everything which for me as i get
to a certain point where it's like
that's why i couldn't get into jurassic
world that looked more fake than
jurassic park i didn't i didn't see
jurassic world maybe that's the same
reason chris pratt's a good guy from
what i hear i i like chris pratt i think
he's fantastic i love that he's
reinvented himself from the funny
heavier guy on parks and recreation to
the the studly dude i think he started
that by playing a seal and uh lone
survivor and then he realized damn i
look pretty good and getting other
offers and then he moved from there well
he was actually pretty like uh pretty
hot stuff on the show ever would he play
like the older brother who was kind of
hunky and then he went to andy yeah it
was like a wb show you probably wouldn't
watch it so much unless it was
smallville i'm sure you checked it
because did you have any cameos yeah i
was on it i was on one episode once
christopher reeve christopher reeve did
an episode and once he did
i i felt an obligation to have to if the
if the the my predecessor did so i had
to did you call them up or do they
they uh they called we're trying to work
out something that would be fun for a
long time and finally i think season
seven i did an episode it was fun well
he's a big guy right that tom welling
yeah he's a big dude he's a big old
country kind of big like he's a big dude
yeah like thick big dude he's probably
six three six four just a big thick dude
oh okay so there you go but did you
attack he's probably still could i
tackle him did you tackle him no i never
tackled him but could i yeah
i'll tackle anybody uh but no he's he's
a he's a big dude i mean he's bigger
he's sure he's clearly bigger than me
but but a really nice guy yeah i've
always heard good things about him all
right i will i won't keep you dean kane
where is the best place for people to
find you obviously supergirl supergirl
yeah well i've got i'm hosting masters
of illusion right now in the cw
season three i hit the floor comes out
i'm there's a lot of other stuff going
on but those are the things that are on
right now um and they can follow me on
twitter at realdean kane i'll say some
things to piss some people off and oh my
gosh well your fans it's almost like the
the gay squad with cher if you say
anything bad about dean cain like how
dare you dean cain is a lovely man good
job i appreciate them fighting for me
that's good uh you get enough people
hate listen twitter it's just so funny
the twitter tough guys they kill me um
but i i tweet twitter tweet twitter i i
treat twitter
tongue tied uh the same as i would you
know like talking to somebody their face
there's nothing i'm gonna say on twitter
that i wouldn't say to your face and i
think everybody should treat it that way
i have to be that way too that's why i
just had to like i was like well i kind
of crapped all over supergirl trailer i
just have to be honest about i don't
know like i just i just cause i don't
want to read it from somewhere else but
stew and put on a face like no i
remember i didn't like the trailer but
um i will give it a shot okay
but that's all right
it may not be for you that's just it and
then i but see people should be afraid
to say it go ahead well i'm going to
give the show a shot again the [ __ ] the
trailer came in and i saw it somewhere
was talk it was a the article i read was
tinged with like a feminist angle on it
so anytime that happens you're like okay
someone's trying to feed me something so
i've got to process this and the black
widow thing just i do get a little upset
not upset i just get annoyed with like a
whole like you know like black widow
okay first off luckily is a terrible
superhero okay she knows no real
superpowers
and she's a woman it's like scarlett
johansson is not going to kick i don't
care how many krav maga people you have
come on the set you're gonna get your
ass kicked by anybody like any man and
then most female athletes who know how
to throw a jab and it's like we all have
to i would know if you don't you're just
there just no i'm just like it's just
it's just tough to buy now supergirl you
can buy because she's basically an alien
life form she is an alien life form no
basically she is she going to go full
species and then like just go to bar
species that was awesome was that not
awesome the original species was natasha
that was amazing it was just like boobs
boobs boobs
yes
one of my favorite pictures really well
you just described it that's the that's
basically my favorite movie well there's
a there's a there's a place now called
the internet you don't have to have the
species vhs but there wasn't back then
this is true the vhs what is she doing
does she still do anything yeah she
still works all the time she does you
know she does different films i've seen
her on all kinds of different stuff she
still works okay it's tougher for a
woman than it is for a man yeah
just no question
and it's not because i made it so
or you but that's just the reality of it
um you know it's like the social status
of of college people
male
senior is probably the highest ranking
social
spot in college and the second highest
is going to be freshman female and the
lowest is a freshman male
it's just the social status it's the way
it kind of worked at least it was where
i went to school and i think it's pretty
similar today you know the young male
you know you're the young cub you don't
have any status until you're a senior
but right behind them is the freshman
female yeah i guess i didn't even really
think about that and that's a good point
i thought about this extensively yes i
was going to say the
the college social hierarchy you've done
your due diligence i didn't create it i
just i'm noting it
yeah i guess i never made it that i i
didn't graduate so i didn't spend a lot
of time she never even got there you
never got to the pinnacle yeah but i was
just such a loudmouth that was like i
might as well have been like was like
you know what you should have you should
create a show
with that loudmouth theme and just call
it louder
i have not it won't work
the name escapes me and hopefully we'll
get some some uh we'll get some
superheroes on the program along with uh
blatantly homosexual super fans and see
how it goes all right dean we won't keep
you um but uh listen thank you so much
we'll get this up on radio we'll get
this up on the youtubes and i will check
out your your football highlight
check that out
i'll feel better because because damn it
american gladiators was not the best
thing i've ever done
i wasn't saying it was just an
impressive performance i'm just kidding
no well it's the funny thing is people
go you play the nfl really
yeah
30 years ago 25 years well it's
basically just you as far as like really
serious athletes in the entertainment
industry it's basically you and uh um ed
o'neill
ed was good yeah ed was no joke and
people don't realize that it's not the
pretty boy
uh who are you talking about kevin uh
kevin um
here comes the boom kevin um kevin james
kevin james actually boss athlete yeah
boss rooten said you know he's like
kevin james hits the pads harder than
anybody i've ever worked and people like
oh you're saying that he's a celebrity
he's like hey kevin if boss says that
it's gonna be the truth okay and he was
really mad that's pretty good that's
pretty good boss rooting he's yeah he's
well you're just amazing does he uh
he teaches there so i haven't met him
yet oh you haven't met him yet but after
that but after i meet him he's gonna
change his statement
kevin james kevin james hit them very
hard dean king it's the most hard of
anyone ever but it's kind of but you
kind of make him sound like odd job
that's all i had
well i'll tell you what tell him we want
him tell him we want him on the program
um because he's also actually you don't
know this he's a conservative he's a
megan kelly fan all right and be careful
he's a perfect example the guy was just
he has um he had a really serious neck
issue so you can see one of his arms is
like degenerated
and it's just sad to say and he's very
open about it it's like you can't
operate at that level for that long but
he was a stud well pat milotic was a
good friend of mine who does a lot of
commentating with him and he said in his
prime no one was a better striker than
palace rooting i it was his kicks that
frightened me oh my gosh just
frightening thunderous just thunderous
and then um i think it was cro cop who
even said like yeah we fooled around
yeah cause his kicks or something yeah
he was on the juice though crow cop he
was over he was like you know how you
know cause chick congo accused him of
being on the juice and he never said no
he's like oh and i suppose chick congo
just ate his vegetables and i was like
yeah exactly it's like ah and then he
came to the states you know and he was
like five pounds heavier and you know
with five percent higher body fat but he
was an incredible athlete anyway so we
keep going we keep trying to let you go
but yeah tell him we want him on the
program because it's boss rooting for
crying out loud he's and he's amazing
he's a great person he's really
hysterical in that oh by the way ed
marinero was a great athlete too who's
an actor oh yeah will hillary
he went to cornell played running back
went to nfl for a long time a great guy
there's a there's a number of them out
there that's true there is a number of
them out there i just mean like you know
people they think oh the guys were in
the best shape are the people on gossip
girls like you know you can fit them in
your back pocket you know ed o'neill you
know he's a multiple uh degree black
belt in brazilian jiu jitsu under henner
right out to anna gracie and her gracie
wow yeah i did not know that yeah he's
no joke and so was a michael clark
duncan was a purple belt under henry
gracie yeah michael i knew and loved um
and it's good that he was a pro and i
love michael and god rest his soul but i
played basketball with him not his sport
no not his sport not his sport unless
you're playing street rules exactly
exactly
i mean that's the nicest guy in the
planet yeah i've heard well henry just
always you know henry was one of the
paul bears and um i've only heard good
things but that's a great example like a
guy like that who's that big
it might i mean it might as well be even
be a different species when you're 340.
you know what i mean that ripped and you
add on top of it knowledge of jiu jitsu
it's like you just pray he just doesn't
feel like raping you that day because
there's nothing you could do you do
nothing and it's a very helpless feeling
yeah
you know what you can do
you can suck your thumb and just take it
just
just take it find your happy place
to get to my happy place
because there's nothing else gonna
happen no there's nothing you can do
about it and it's like and i think
especially like you're a big guy i'm a
relatively big guy and with knowledge
like well in most instances i'd be able
to not embarrass myself and then michael
clark duncan happens and you're like
there's
well like you know i just have to take
like our brock lesnar that place find
your happy place just fine happy place i
just did a movie called vendetta with a
big show
www oh yeah yeah yeah he's not as mobile
though no not his mobile he's got a knee
thing and he's seven foot you know 350
pounds yeah but uh we had to fight all
the time and you know we're doing our
fights and things and what he just
missed on a real short right that
literally grazed my nose which would
have reset my face um and i hit him
square in the forehead an uppercut
square right in the forehead nothing and
no he looks up he just goes come on and
i was like
i don't know what that means and can we
cut real quick because i don't know he
went just let's keep going yeah but i
thought maybe i made him angry and then
he wanted to thump me in which case i
would start running right use my speed
you could hit a low single get him down
and like curb stomp him and run
yeah you get up so you have to like
and apologize profusely as you're
running away
really sorry maybe you'll be happy
tomorrow when you catch me
yeah i think your self-defense is a
concealed carry permit at that point uh
yeah which which which
which is a good thing it's good but it's
very difficult
yeah i know
okay we won't talk about he's like we
won't talk about this on air believe me
i know gage aaron's actually a pretty
good shot he always makes fun of me
because i'm a big revolver guy and he
has his uh ballers are amazing yeah i
know he always craps all over me for him
i don't know listen if you need more
than seven shots six shots in your see
there you go i know you know revolvers
because a seven shot is only smith and
wesson j uh l frame so you know you're
revolving a little get a little speed
loader you're all right you're all right
dean kane you must go thank you so much
we will have you back on soon i'd love
to be on thanks all right take care man
gay jared hang up
hi youtube bisexual subscribe by
clicking my face or liking one of these
videos next to me if you're not bisexual
you're still allowed to subscribe
but i won't be as happy about it